Happy Halloween!
Almost.
Spooky!
Hello, Kaini Dasai Masen!
Welcome to...
Isn't there such a lovely castle behind me?
I'm the...
I feel like the guard dog.
Because I'm like...
Because I'm...
Um...
But...
But I...
I should check a mirror?
I can't see my reflection.
Is something wrong?
Is everything okay?
I have ketchup on my face?
I didn't have a hamburger today, so...
Jelly donut, no.
Oh!
Sorry.
Halloween falls on a Thursday, the 23rd this year?
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
That's my birthday, bros!
Have a happy birthday!
MGS birthday song.
Sorry, I have no MGS today.
Oh, the MGS birthday song I can do it real quick This is for everybody whose birthday it is today This is For everybody whose birthday it is Or Pack type happy birthday Or if your birthday was yesterday Or tomorrow Well, I'll still be streaming tomorrow
Happy birthday Congratulations Happy birthday with salutation Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
To all and to all a good night!
Not a good night.
Spooky night!
Today I have some spooky songs to sing for you all.
Some of them are more spooky than others, maybe.
it's a lot of songs that I don't think I have ever sung in karaoke before, so I'm very nervous.
I'm scared, but it's all fun, right?
It's all fun.
It's just a...
It's just a karaoke.
Spooky.
That's the scariest part.
But because I have a set list, No requests today.
I'm sorry.
I did ask for requests for Membouz for Halloween songs.
And many, many people gave me many, many suggestions.
And so I took some of those that I felt like I knew or I could learn.
Some of these I learned like yesterday, so if I mess up...
If I mess up...
Yeah.
It's like your style, Minto.
Thanks.
But, uh, yeah.
There, you know, if you wanted a song, a Halloween song, I might be singing it.
So actually, I'm gonna write that real quick.
Please, no requests.
I have a set list.
Smiley face.
I have.
I don't have a smiley face.
I mean, I do have a smiley face.
Yeah.
I have a job interview today!
Is it okay if you can share your not-freaky Minto energy?
But my energy is always kind of freaky.
Um...
Uh...
Good.
You got this!
I also...
I got new headphones recently, you guys.
it moon drop I E M's it's really weird it's really weird with them mmm sounds fancy it's not quite good choice yeah they do fit well yeah they're inside my ears oh they have left and right labels they don't which I got the Aria 2.
So far I do like them.
Sometimes they crackle a little.
I don't know if that's because of my setup or...
I don't know if that's because of my setup or what.
Because if it's like I have so many cables everywhere.
But...
But yeah.
No left or right that's risky.
Wait, actually...
I wonder if I could test it somehow.
Actually you got... But I think I have it right.
I think so.
Maybe.
Aria 2 should have labels.
Oh.
They didn't pin the message before.
Yes, I did.
I see a pinned right there.
I'm literally looking at them.
I see no left or right.
Well, they are red and black, maybe.
Maybe that's what you mean.
But also, they are made for specific ears, so you can't mix it up.
You can't mix it up, because one's shaped for one ear and one's shaped for the other ear.
So...
Whose blood is that?
It's the person that tried to enter the castle earlier.
And now, if you think you are worthy of entering the castle to meet my Ojo-sama, you must listen to my song.
I must serenade you.
I don't know what to start with.
I think I'm just gonna go in the order of what I wrote down.
Sure.
I'll just go in the order of what I wrote down.
This one's a classic.
This one is like the Halloween song.
Well not the Halloween.
It is a, it's, you'll know, you'll know, you'll know.
What if I'm not here for Ojo Sama and the gate guard is cute?
I'm not, uh, I am not, I'm, there's no route for me.
Yeah, I'm only unlockable in the DLC, maybe.
And you will get that in 10 years, maybe.
It ought to be illegal for ghosts to somehow keep getting cuter.
Foolish mortal.
Samoa, thank you so much for the 10 gifts, and thank you.
Okay.
Are we ready?
I'm going to sing.
This is a fun one to start with.
Yeah, let's go!
outfits look so rad for spooky karaoke thank you thank you wait oh wait what does it mean that the song you are trying to play is not available
we're doing it live we're doing it live
is it gonna
blow how you
see a sight that almost stops your heart you try to scream But the terror takes the sound before you make it You start to breeze As horror looks you right between the eyes You're paralyzed Cause this is Thriller, Thriller Night And no one's gonna save you from the beast about to strike You know it's Thriller,
Thriller Night You're fighting for your life Killer, thriller tonight.
That was the audio.
You hear the door slam and realize there's nowhere left to run.
Oh yeah, feel the cold hand and wonder if you'll ever see the sun.
You close your eyes and hope that this is just imagination.
But all the while You hear a creature creeping up behind You're out of time Cause this is thriller Thriller night There ain't no second chance Against a thing with 40 eyes, girl
You're fighting for your life Inside a killer, thriller tonight and the dead start to walk.
Oh wait, I think I got the part wrong.
I thought this was, what's his name's part?
Where he just starts talking.
Sorry.
When does that guy start talking?
They're out again.
Prince and Prince, this evening's closing in on every side.
They will possess you.
Unless you change that number on your dial Now is the time for you and I to cuddle close together All through the night I'll save you from the terror on the screen I'll make you see That it's a thriller, thriller night Cause I can thrill you more than any ghost would ever dare try I am the ghost So let me hold you tight And share a killer Diller Ow!
Cause it's a thriller Would
ever dare try
So let me hold you tight And share a killer thriller Ow!
Gonna thrill you tonight Baby?
Hey, no I wanted to say this part Surprise!
Good night hours close at hand.
Creatures crawl in search of blood to terrorize y'all's neighborhood.
I'm gonna thrill you tonight, baby.
I didn't realize this song turned into a love song.
We have the soul full of getting down.
Must stand and face the hands of hell and rot inside the house's shell.
Oh, baby.
I'm gonna thrill you tonight.
Yeah, baby.
Oh, darling!
The foulest stenches in the air.
The funk of 40,000 years.
And grizzly goons from every tomb are close-finned to seal your doom.
And when you fight to stay alive, Your body starts to shiver before no immortal can resist.
Wait, I'm going to hear his laugh.
Yay, that was thriller.
I'm getting used to these new headphones.
So sorry if I'm like constantly asking what the volume is like.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wow, that was very thrilling, was it?
I guess they are on a date, huh, in the music video.
I never even thought about it Next song, next song I passed my driving test I brought Minto Pledge for good luck And she did good work You even parallel parked and everything Or did you let her do it She doesn't have a license Congratulations Lucky, lucky,
hold on, I mean Frankie Frankie next song I'm gonna sing some songs I sung last year during a Halloween themed karaoke let me double check that this is good but um yeah it's a fun song so I like this song let me see let me see
okay this should be fine I don't remember what I used before So
Hopefully this is an acceptable value But This next song is from one of my favorite idol groups ever AQ Zombina Wait, wait, Zombina But that's not the name of the group, that's the name of the song Of Dempagumi Inc.
is the name of the idol group Okay, let's try...
Zombie, zombie, zombie.
Zombie, zombie!
Zombie song.
Hold on, I'm setting it up.
Oh, you can't hear.
Sorry, I just realized.
There we go.
Okay.
Wait, that's me.
When did I record these?
What did I record this?
Happy Halloween!
Wait!
It's been a whole year since I've last listened to this.
Zombie.
Zombie-na!
I love
you Wow, I love you I love you Oh, oh, oh, glib, go away She loves you Even though it's too long Even when you're still alive
Oh, I love you I love you I love you
That was AQ Zambina, such a cute song.
I love that it's like so country and spooky at the same time.
The dance for it is very cute too.
Yay!
I have insane news.
I'm going to be a parent!
Wait.
Hmm?
Are you a ghost because you've been haunting my dreams!
Oh!
Yes, actually, I am a ghost.
I'm very real ghost.
I read the full message.
What do I say?
Congrats at the baby.
The next song I'm going to sing, I also sang last year.
I actually thought about not singing it this year, but I was like, no, I'm going to sing it this year because it's a Halloween song.
And it's composed by one of my favorite artists ever, Mosaic Wave.
And also performed by one of my favorite idol groups ever.
And I...
Wait, where's the MP3?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, just kidding.
And I...
What was I going to say?
Oh, okay, wait, I want to spoil something.
So I'm performing next week at U.S.
Idol Festival.
And I know it's Halloween weekend, but I'm actually not performing on Halloween.
But I made my set list before I knew.
And so my theme for my set list was kind of Halloween songs.
Plus, like, I kind of was like, maybe I can kind of like show my appeal by being made by singing some really cute songs so they're kind of like it's like a progression of like halloween to cute song progression but they're all also kind of like spooky ish not all of them what's my set list again but anyway it's still halloween weekend if it's yeah i perform the day after halloween so everybody should still have a little bit of Halloween spirit,
right?
And so this is a song that I'm also going to be singing.
It's called Lumpling Box.
And so I want to sing it so that people can get used to the song because maybe it's not a super duper popular song in the West, but if I want to perform it all the time, I should just, I should contact Mosaic Wave and be like,
the same for me like make this song number two for me and so the song is called you can look up you probably will find calls and stuff for it lumpling box but i want to help you guys for for for when i perform it because it's very fun i think in my opinion dark mental yeah i'm
If lumping box is so good, why is there no lumping box too?
I could beat the lumping box too.
Can you teach us the calls?
Yeah, that's what I'm going to do and try.
So I'm going to half sing and half do calls, okay?
Actually, wait.
What if I sing it first and then I do the calls, do second version?
I'll try that.
It's kind of the song, the calls are really fine, so.
Okay.
Okay, I sing it first.
I'm resisting doing the calls!
I'm back!
I'm
back!
I'm a girl, the moon gets lit up by the moon.
Tainty-cold is the end, the dark-earth cabot-cha-cha-wa-la-lou In the middle of the moon, there's a man-in-the-git-o-pa-no-oh-hime-same A-bosiggy box, I'll open it more, it won't stop.
The adults, the children, all of you, all look at me.
Come here, come here,
A hundred-year-old wakwak tower
Kuro-nako's Kuro-nako's o-sasoying, a candle-moto-moto Yibutsu-no-tomobo-tach Ono-tangita present Semi-garned-me-garned Me-garned-me-garnet-mokete Moku-teak-i-moro-do-ji-sama A-bosiggy-no-box Ike-tara-more-tomara-tay Oh-bake
Time Tata
Tata Tata Tata Tata Tata
Let's check our tree Party one more Oh, so, so do Oh, here we go, This is the night, we'll go We'll go to the next morning Oh, Chant, Dun, Dun, Dun This is the end of the showtime So ding, Dun, Dun Oh, ding, Dun Oh, the end of the show
Maybe I'll just...
I'll just show you guys later.
I'm half-faced.
How do I fix the camera?
Wait, I'm gonna scoot over a little.
Wait, I can't scoot over a little.
Oh, why is the camera always so weird to me?
Pleasure ride, thank you for rendering, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, you know what, let's just go to the next song, I'm embarrassed now.
I don't
know how to speak anymore.
Let's do another Japanese song while I'm in JP mood.
Actually,
I just realized I did not find a karaoke for this prior.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no.
Wait, I can find it.
I can find it.
I can do it.
We're doing it live.
This should be fine.
Let me double check it.
Oh, it's loud.
What song is this?
What am I listening to?
No, it's not this one.
Oh, wait, is it this one?
Oh, this is, this works, this works, this works.
Okay, next is everybody, everybody should know this song, too.
Everybody should know this song, too.
I have a mix of Japanese and English songs.
I can't type either, I can't speak, I can't type.
Sorry, it goes off the thing.
Live, baby, live.
We're doing it live.
We're always doing it live.
Is this carry?
Okay.
I thought
they just included the background singers.
Okay.
Sorry, no background singers.
I'll do the same thing.
I'll take all the blood
from the blood to the dead.
I'll do it.
I'll take my hand to my my fingers.
I'll take it to the end.
The day's grayish is dark and darkens the night I'll do the dance.
I'll do it again.
I'll do it.
🎵
🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵
🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵 Oh, I've got to go in a little bit.
In the light of the light, I'm going to sit up there with a number of hands.
Come on, someone else will come to this place.
The other way, here, the hand will turn toward the way.
No need to move.
The only problem is I don't know when I come
here.
The only problem is I don't know when I come here.
The second one
got me
Thank you.
I didn't see the super chat, but I saw the notification of someone saying that they're new or who has been wondering about recording this or something.
But yes, feel, of course, I've had people clip and record the karaoke's before.
So, of course.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you for asking, though.
I really appreciate it.
Hayden, thank you so much for the vibe.
Good day.
Thank you guys all for the silver chats and the donuts and everything and the gifted memberships.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Let's see.
What's on my list?
I'm crossing out the ones that I've done.
this next song.
I sung quite recently, I think.
I think it fits... Wait, hold on.
I have to find the lyrics.
There we go.
I think it fits... Especially how I look.
I kind of look like a vampire, right?
A little bit.
I think.
Maybe I shouldn't do all the Japanese songs at once.
I don't know.
Who cares?
It's my karaoke.
where is it I found it what's the difference I don't think there is one okay let me hold on let me make sure it's not too loud for you guys oh it's too quiet for you guys okay I turn it up the red certainly lends itself to that If I had a tube, one more tooth.
No, Vampire Minto, don't drink my blood.
Give me your blood.
Kanye East.
Thank you for that, guys.
I love it.
Healthcare installment.
Part I lost count.
I haven't been sick, so thank you.
Thank you.
All right.
Next song up.
We've got...
Actually, I don't know.
Well...
oh well okay yesterday i like had a crazy my i woke up with a headache and then it turned into a migraine it was so bad that doesn't count though right i'm b plus drink up i have only ectoplasm but when i was alive i don't think i knew my my blood type what type do you think i would Because there's different,
like, the different blood types have, like, different, what do you call?
Personality types, sort of, right?
M, G, for ghost.
Like, that's a blood type.
My type.
Are you saying I'm your type?
How what is all the Japanese games from the 90s teaching us about blood types is that still like common in Japan I wonder too if they're like if they if they're still very I mean I think they still know their blood type but do they still like kind of really care about the blood type
maybe i'm just not paying attention
i just had some gamer subs wow yummy yeah it's very much like a horoscope thing where it's like astrology like are our blood types compatible you're a plus to me use code boomer for gamer subs Oops!
Yippee!
How about...
A horror scope?
Yes.
Spooky.
Just like this next song.
Well, I'm close.
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
.
Enkai, giri, giri, hako, suzen, cures Nibane, ikite, delu,
no, zetakui, wana Oish-souda, o-soukno, zirruin Oish-sou!
I give you good things in the dark, in the
dark, but wait, just do it, do it, do it, do it!
Shannily, shannily, oh, jannily Kha'aiowae aura de mado'asel If you look at her eyes, look at her eyes Her blue, yellowy hair, red lips, vampire girl CUNY I've been love you, oh, oh, oh, oh The most loved one of you before you Kyo-sun Zen Kyo-i I'm an otome chick I love you,
I know I love it all It's a delicious-sou-y-na-no Chiruru
Masha-na-same-luc-noyam Shandari, shandari Ojo-sama A hundred-year-old A-hito-nino-seh-seh-moke
That was a cune-a-vampy vampire Aka-e-cuchibiru Bana-na-na-na-na-na Shunari-shanari-a-nariu Shunariu-sha-nariu-sama A hundred years ago Nolita A-shita-he-shita A-se-w-mookery Nubii-no-hitori Nureta-matzge-no Vampire-girl CUNE
That was a CUNE Vampire-girl Yeah, yeah, yeah Did it make you feel so cune-cune-cune-cune-tastic?
Hold on, let me drink some more water.
I mean, not water.
I'm drinking blood.
Because I'm a vampire today.
Or...
What if I'm not a vampire?
Hmm?
What if...
What if I'm not a vampire?
What if instead...
I'm...
A cannibal!
I've only heard this song through Nimmy.
I had to learn it.
Cannibal!
Let's go.
Wait.
Hold on.
Sorry, redo?
Sorry.
I realized the vocals were on.
I have a heart, I swear I do, but that's not baby when it comes to you.
When you say you love me, harsh if you know what's good for you.
I think you're hot, I think you're cool.
You're the kind of guy I'd stalk in school.
But now that I'm famous, you're up my anus.
Now I'm gonna eat you, fool.
I eat boys up, breakfast and lunch.
Then when I'm thirsty, I drink their blood.
Carnivore animal, I am a cannibal.
I eat boys up, you better run.
I am cannibal.
I am cannibal I'll eat you up I am cannibal I'll
eat you up Whatever you tell me, I'm pretty That's when the hunger really hits me Your little heart goes pitter-patter I want your liver on a platter Use your finger to stir my tea Then for dessert Suck your teeth, be too sweet and you'll be a goner Yep,
I'll pull a Jeffrey Dahmer I eat boys up, breakfast and lunch Then when I'm thirsty, I suck their blood Carnivore animal, I am a cannibal I eat boys up, you'd better run I'm a cannibal
I am a cannibal
I am cannibal
I'll beat you up I
am cannibal
I warned you
I am cannibal This song is so fun actually Sorry I tripped over some of the lyrics though I tried practicing but I have a performance anxiety Yeah!
Did you think that was the only cannibal song I had tonight?
Of course not.
Of course that's not the other only cannibal song I have tonight.
That would be ridiculous.
That would be so silly if I only had...
After all the games I've played recently that involve cannibalism, I of course have to sing the cannibal song.
I have to sing more cannibal.
You're walking in the woods.
There's no one around and your phone is dead.
Out of the corner of your eye, you see him.
He's following you about 30 feet back.
He gets down on all fours and breaks into a sprint.
He's gaining on you.
Shail above.
You're looking for your car, but you're all turned around.
He's almost upon you now, and you can see there's blood on his face.
My God, there's blood everywhere!
Running for your life?
Oh, he's brandishing a knife.
It's Shia LaBeouf, lurking in the shadows.
Hollywood superstar, Shia LaBeouf, living in the woods, Shia LaBeouf, killing for sport, Shia LaBeouf, eating all the bodies.
Now it's dark and you seem to have lost him, but you're hopelessly lost yourself.
Stranded with a murderer, you creep silently through the underbrush.
Aha!
In the distance, a small cottage with a light on.
Hope.
You move stealthily toward it.
But your leg!
Ah!
It's caught in a bear trap!
Drawing off your leg!
Quiet, quiet.
Limping to the cottage.
Now you're on the doorstep.
Sitting inside.
Shia LaBeouf, sharpening an axe, Shia LaBeouf, but he doesn't hear you enter.
Shia LaBeouf, you're sneaking up behind him, strangling superstar Shia LaBeouf, fighting for your life with Shia LaBeouf, wrestling a knife from Shia LaBeouf, stab it in his kidney, safe and last from Shia LaBeouf.
You limp into the dark woods, blood oozing from your stump leg.
You've beaten him, Shia LaBeouf.
Wait, he isn't dead, shy of surprise There's a gun to your head and death in his eyes But you can do just that soon Body slam superstar, Shia LaBeouf You can carry fight with Shia LaBeouf Normal Tuesday night for Shia LaBeouf You try to swing an axe at Shia LaBeouf But Drev is fading fast when you're stumbling He's dodging every swipe,
he parries to the left You counter to the right, you catch him in the neck You're chopping off his head now his head topples to the floor expressionless.
You fall to your knees and catch your breath.
You're finally safe from Shia LaBeouf.
Oh my god.
Are you?
Who knows?
We need a part two.
How do some of you not know this song?
It's Shia LaBeouf song.
How do you guys not know?
Can you see a reflection?
Are you vampire cannibal?
Vampire cannibal?
I'm a ghost, actually.
I'm just cosplaying today.
Oh, that's okay.
This song is like an internet classic.
An elf called an irkling.
Original meaning elf king.
Lured kids away with songs to eat them.
Oh.
Yummy.
Shadow Cross, thank you so much for the time, get the!
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, you guys should, if you've never seen the Shia LaBeouf's Cannibal song, I recommend you go watch it.
Because the original is so, it's like the most high effort shitpost ever.
Cosplaying is always okay.
What do you mean, by the?
I'm not always cosplaying.
I'm like,
hmm love that song yeah hold on let me exit out these songs uh what do i want to do next let's do some more halloween well these are all halloween songs what am i talking about let's do oh i did this one too sorry i don't have like the set list written but I figured I figured like it takes up space so instead today I decided to do the now playing I hope you guys don't mind um we'll do this song because then I can do lots of funny voices let's do yeah this one this
one Boys and girls of every age Would you like to see something strange?
Come with us and you will see This our town of Halloween This is Halloween This is Halloween Pumpkins scream in the dead of night This is Halloween Everybody make a scene Trick or treat Till a neighbor's gonna die a fright It's our town
I am the one hiding under your bed.
Teeth ground sharp and eyes glowing red.
I am the one hiding under your stairs.
Fingers like snakes and spiders in my hair.
This is Halloween.
Halloween, Halloween, Halloween, Halloween.
In this town, we call home.
Everyone hail to the pumpkin song.
In this town, don't we love it now?
Everybody's waiting for the next one.
Surprise!
Round that corner man hiding in the trash can Something's waiting out to pounce And how you'll scream!
Halloween, red and black and slimy green Aren't you scared?
Well, that's just fine!
Say it once, say it twice Take a chance and roll the dice Ride with the moon in the dead of night Everybody scream!
Everybody scream!
In our town of Hall I am the cloud with a tear-away face Here in a flash and gone without a trace I am the one when you call who's there.
I am the wind blowing through your head.
I am the shadow on the moon at night, filling your dreams to the brim with fright.
This is Halloween, this is Halloween.
Halloween, Halloween, Halloween, Halloween.
Who is that?
Tender lovelings everywhere.
There's no fun without a good scare.
That's our job, but we're not me.
of Halloween.
This, this town, don't we love it now?
Everyone's waiting for the next surprise.
Skeleton Jack might catch you in the back and scream like I'm crunchy, make you jump out of your skin.
This is Halloween, everybody screamed.
Dreams make way for a very special god.
Our man Jack is king on the pumpkin patch.
Everyone hail to the pumpkin king.
Oh, this is Halloween.
This is Halloween.
Halloween, Halloween.
Halloween In this town We call home Everyone hail to the pumpkin song La la la la la La la la la la la La la la
la Yeah
This is Halloween It is Halloween Next week Next week Next week Next week Yeah
Halloween which means that if Halloween is next week that means that October is already over like next week October will be over then it's November and then you guys like you start getting so busy it's fun stuff but stuff that some stuff are event things like I have the Asa Yoru cafe that got collab cafe that got announced recently and I have to the year which got announced and then i have a little bit of not a little bit i have a lot of travel in november i'm so sorry november became super duper busy for me
but um yeah busy busy busy and then i have some other fun stuff planned for starting next year some things i have not been announced yet actually several in many things i have not been announced yet i feel like i don't have a break i'm like i was i was thinking i was like do it when when do i have a month of nothing and i don't know i guess technically well this month technically i had nothing so i think this month is this month and maybe January are my only two months of nothing until like until I don't know hmm
I don't feel like I'm overworking myself some of it is travel travel is the hardest stuff I've been trying to cut back on that as much as possible if I can help it but yeah concert this month yeah but like but that was that's different that was for my birthday that wasn't like an event or like an event I mean like uh or well
so but but but but every but I'll it should all be fun stuff so I'm not taking requests please look at the pinned message thank you though I'm about I'm in a store with my earbuds and I can't stop giggling about Shia LeBuff I look at what do you mean you hold my step in a puddle of my socks that's so mean
I liked the Shia LeBuff song you can't say something that doesn't count because it's not the biggest thing you've done yet well well well October is almost over which means Mariah Carey is almost here no don't think about her I will flash freeze her so she's not thawed yet she still has one week I will I will feed her soup that makes her go to sleep for a week at the minimum I don't know what the maximum might be it depends on if I get the correct dosage or not but I I won't have anybody coming in and saying Mariah Carey.
Not yet.
Not on my watch.
It's Halloween time.
It's my favorite time of the year right now.
Oh my gosh, guys.
No Christmas.
No mentioning.
Unless it's Nightmare Before Christmas.
Which I just sang.
Let's hear.
I'll hear.
The next song will make you forget about, about,
about it.
It's...
Spooky, scary skeleton.
Shock your soul.
Failure do tonight.
Spooky, scary skeleton.
Skeletons speak with such a screech.
Shake and shudder in surprise when you hear these zombies shriek.
We're so sorry.
Skeletons, you're so misunderstood.
You only want to socialize, but I don't think we should.
Cause spooky, scary skeletons shout startling, surely screams.
There's sarcophagus and just won't let you be.
Bro are shy, what's all the fuss?
But bags of bone seem so unsafe, it's semi-serious.
Spooky, scary skeletons are silly, all the same.
They'll smile and scramble slowly by and drive you so insane.
Sticks and stones will break your bones They'll seldom let you snooze Spooky scary skeletons will wake you with a bell
Caprizu, no thank you so much for the ticket
Her song on repeat here, it's...
No!
No, no, no, this is why I'm here to keep you in the spooky mood Here, here, here, here, here, here, here, here.
Another one, another one, another one.
This one I'm nervous about.
I didn't know it very well, so I think I'll mess it up.
Sorry, in advance.
What happened?
I've been messing up today, though.
The skeleton sang it wrong?
So true!
Boo.
Okay, hold on.
My throat.
That's okay, that's why I have a set list, so I know exactly how many songs I'm singing today.
Spooky, scary skeletons.
I put a spell on you.
You can't stop the things I do.
I ain't lying.
Oh, it's been 300 years, right down to the Now the witch is back and there's hell to pay.
I put a spell on you.
And now you're fine.
Hello, say love.
My name is Mito.
What's yours?
I put a spell on you.
And now you're gone And
it was strong Your precious little lives have all been cursed Cause of all the witches working I'm the worst I put a spell on you And now you're mine Let's watch out She's lying If you don't believe You better get superstitious Ask my sisters I put a spell on you.
A wicked spell.
I put a spell on you.
Sisters, I say intopai, alpha money, up and dame.
I say intopai, alpha maybe up and dame.
Incoma koriama.
Hey, ha, yes, bye, bye.
Yeah, that was I put a spell on you.
you're from hocus pocus
hocus pocus yeah hold on let's do more goth girls well that's not really goth girls but wait hold on i gotta listen to the beginning of this one real quick i don't remember
okay uh i might mess this up so i'm gonna sing with the lead vocal kind of quiet Oh, that's okay.
Oh, thank you so much for the...
I have to get the deck!
Apple, you're as welcome back!
Happy to be under your spell.
Okay.
I try this song.
Sorry if I mess it up.
Sorry.
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, wait.
You can't hear it.
My bad.
I'm gonna cast a spell on you You're gonna do what I want you to do Mix it up here in my little bowl Say a few words and you lose control I'm a Hex girl and I'm gonna put a spell on you I'm gonna put a spell on you I'm a Hex girl and I'm gonna put a spell on you Yeah!
You'll feel the fog as I cloud your mind You'll get dizzy when I make the sign You'll wake up in the dead of night Missing me when I'm out of sight I'm a hex girl And I'm gonna put a spell on you I'm gonna put a spell on you I'm gonna put a spell on you Oh yeah This little cobweb potion You'll fall into dark devotion If you ever lose affection I can change your whole direction I'm a hex girl And I'm gonna put a spell on you I'm gonna put a spell on you I'm a hex girl And I'm gonna put a spell on you
on you sorry i tried learning that song for today it's only a minute long i was like try to learn it oops sorry oh well that was the hex girls from scoby do scoby do scoby scoby scoby scoby do
She's a mint girl!
I'm gonna put a spell on you!
Are you going to become...
Wait, are you going to put the become tasty spell on us, Miss Cannibal?
What, like a mo... Am I gonna moi moi cue you?
Ugh.
Hold on.
I thought this would be...
My ear is getting uncomfy.
Oh no.
I wonder if maybe the IEM is not for me.
Hmm.
Muay, Muay, Q.
Okie dokie.
Jankie.
Jankies.
Looking at the hex girls, like look at what they need to mimic a fraction of my power.
What do you mean?
What?
Um.
Let's do this song next.
Because this one's fun.
And you can dance to it with me.
Yeah.
Do you guys know the dance?
It's just to jump to the left.
Right?
It's easy.
Where's the
music?
Hello?
Oh, there it is.
It's astounding.
Time is fleeting.
Madness takes its toll.
But listen closely.
Not for very much longer.
I've got to keep control.
I remember
drinking those moments.
Let's do the time warp again.
It's just a jump to the left.
And then a step to the right.
With your hands on your hips.
You'll bring your knees in tight.
But let's do the time warp again.
Let's do the time warp again It's so dreamy Oh, fantasy free me So you can't see me No, not at all In another dimension With voyeuristic intention Well secluded I see all With
time slip And nothing Can't ever be the same You're spaced out in sensation Like you're under sedation Let's do the cyborg again Let's do the cyborg again Well, I was walking down the street just to have
us Let's do the cyborg again
Again Let's just jump to
the You bring your knees and top
Let's do the time warp again Let's do the time warp again
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm,
hmm Hmm, hmm, hmm Look at the lemon go Thank you, Mr. Super Tom Thank you, thank you, thank you That was the time warp from Rocky horror picture show I've never I've well I've seen the movie obviously but I've never gone to like one of the theater shows to see it I kind of want to one day I feel like it might be fine to like but I'm also scared of what all people do in there I don't it's fun it's a lot of fun it's somewhat an accident it it's a secret what's a secret live performance rule rules or there are rules
wait i thought the spoons were for the room they throw toilet paper at the screen do i need to bring toilet paper it's not used is it
whole audience yeah yeah the whole audience gets involved.
That's kind of why I want to go.
Spoons is the room.
Right, yeah, because the spoons are in the picture frames.
Yeah.
Take a raincoat.
Ew, why?
Be careful the splash zone.
With the toilet, the toilet paper.
Wait, what's the toilet?
I'm scared.
Maybe I don't want to go in here.
anymore now I'm scared I wonder if there's one like happening close to me uh maybe like next week or something I probably still won't go I'm scared rice there are super soakers involved oh it's not what you think the raincoat is for poop and pee oh obviously
Duh.
This one, this next one is something that somebody requested.
They suggested it.
And I ended up really liking it, so I added it to the set list.
But I learned it just for this, so sorry again if I mess it up.
But, hold on, let me hear how it starts, and then I should be able to remember.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I think I got it.
Let's turn off the vocal.
Okay.
Ugh, my throat today.
I'm so sorry.
After this, I'll take a little mint.
And I will take...
Not a break, but like, I'll...
Actually, how many songs do I have left?
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Oh, there's quite a lot of songs.
I sing!
This one is called Necromancing Dancing by Bear Ghost.
This is it, now we found it, I'm astounded Every time we'll be surrounded by a throng of marching dead Delicious, the riches, they glisten ahead It's a craze, they'll devour every hour of this endless Non-progressive inundations of their kind And lucky for you,
you're next on in line When I'm necromancing Everyone's dancing, no one can stop me, I dare you to try The dead are infused with sensational groove And they're coming for you, now there's nowhere to hide Yeah, I'm raising the dead I'm loving the dread Let's make some evil
I'm in bliss, my cadavers drive a gathering People, people, seeing the deceased advance The risen or risen with rhythm and dance Dig up some flesh with plenty of mold Diseases appeasing for rickety bones And make it saucy with a hot incantation Dominion is served with a bubbling spirited,
vibrant subjugation Yeah I'm raising the day Have love in the dread Let's make some evil Yes, the dance of the dead Get out there and shred Let's make some evil
Cities lay waste and they celebrate Free now from their graves
So mints and proud It's over now Back from Las Valle You're all the same
Yeah, I'm raising the day I'm loving the dress Let's make some evil yeah the dance of the day get out there and shred and make some evil
gosh i might have to check the band out i've never heard of them before bear ghost song is so fun necromancing dancing yeah thank you to whoever recommended it Good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good.
The next song is also one that I've never sung before.
I'm gonna have to pull it up.
It's a Japanese, we're going, I think it's my last Japanese song, actually.
It is, I think, my last one.
Oh, let's try.
I try, I'm scared.
I think it's this one that I was doing, I practiced with before.
Um.
Oh, hold on.
Let me make sure it's not too loud and too soft or whatever, whatever.
This song is called, Suki Suki.
Dai Suki.
Yay!
By Togawa Jun.
on today
guys sorry
i tried the verses are like such a weird tempo.
Sorry.
Whoopsie.
Yeah!
Soky, soky, die, soky.
Let's do it.
Actually, I'll do this one then since I just did that one.
I'll do my best, but I don't know.
I might not be able to hit the note today.
Let me try.
We'll see.
Maybe.
In
sleepy sand to me, in dreams he came.
That voice which calls to me and speaks my name.
And do I dream again?
For now I fall.
And all of the opera is there inside my mind.
Oh, you turn from me to glance behind.
The
opera is there inside your mind.
Yeah, get it.
Those who have seen your face draw back in fear.
I am the mask you wear.
It's me they hear.
My spirit and my voice in one combined.
The phantom of the opera is there inside my mind.
Oh, I'm nervous.
Fantasies, you always knew that modern mystery were both in your mind.
you and in this labyrinth where night is blind the phantom of the opera is here inside my mind
He's there, the
first...
I'm going to stand, who?
To the scene of sweet music's throne.
To this kingdom where all must pay homage to music.
You have come here for one purpose and one alone.
Since the moment I first heard you sing I have needed you with me Why is this guy yapping at the end of the song?
For my music Shut up I have no more parts That was the Phantom of the Opera
Oh I was so nervous I was so nervous Oh my gosh I second-guessed myself.
That's why I didn't do it on the right time.
Sorry.
Ever since COVID, it's been very hard for me to hit when I got COVID a couple of years ago.
When was that?
I don't remember.
But it's harder for me to hit the high notes because of it.
So I feel... I feel...
I feel good!
Yippee!
Yay!
Thank you guys for all the super chats!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Valentine, thank you so much for the Hawkeye Super Bowl!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Yay!
Okay, I saw a few songs.
Left though, I got the hard ones out of the way.
Actually, there's one song.
You know what?
I'm just...
No.
Well...
Okay, I didn't practice this one at all.
I thought it would be fun to do it live.
Okay.
Um, this one, um, I didn't practice it at all.
I don't even, I think I listened to the song twice.
And, um, yep, I'm just gonna do my best.
And, uh, this one's for you.
you.
Vicky, this one's for you.
I put it on my list and then I kept skipping over it for some reason.
I think I forgot that I put it there or I was confusing it with a different song or something and I forgot.
So I didn't practice it.
We're doing it live.
We're doing a lot.
You know me, the fighting freak knuckles?
We're at Pumpkin Hill.
You ready?
I ain't gonna let it get to me.
I'm just gonna creep down in Pumpkin Hill.
I got to find my last piece.
I know that it's here.
I can sense it within my feet.
A great emerald's power allows me to feel.
I can't see a thing, but it's around somewhere.
I'm gonna hold my head because I have no fear.
Crazy, crazy, a graveyard theory.
A ghost tried to approach me and got leery.
Asked him a question and he vanished in a second.
I'm walking through the valley, some crying pumpkin in the alley.
Didn't seem happy, but they sure got to give me.
Had to get him back up with a fist-metal crackup.
I'm hearing someone say, you're a chicken, don't be scared.
I had to be the wind because nobody wasn't there.
I searched and researched as I climbed up the wall.
And then I started to fly.
I went in deeper.
I know that it's here I sense it in my feet The great emerald's power Allows me to feel I can't see a thing But it's around here somewhere Gotta hold my head I have no fear The world sees crazy crazy A graveyard theory A ghost tried to approach me He got leery
This is Knuckles Who fears none It's It's Wait When is it this part.
Wait.
Real deal when it comes to my name, kid.
I'm gonna just creep.
Down in Pumpkin Hill, I gots to find my last piece.
I know that it's here.
I can sense it in my feet.
The great emerald's power allows me to feel.
I can't see a thing, but it's around somewhere.
I gotta hold my head, cause I have no fear.
This probably seems crazy, crazy graveyard theory.
A ghost tried to approach me and got leery.
Ask him a question and he vanished in a second.
I'm walking through valleys crying pumpkin in the alley.
Didn't seem happy but they sure tried to get me.
Had to back him up with the fist metal.
Crack him.
Because no one wasn't there.
I searched and I searched as I climbed up the wall and then I started to fly.
I went in deeper.
Let it get to me.
I'm just gonna creep down a pumpkin hill.
I got some fun with hot bees.
Know that it's here.
I sense it in my feet.
The great emerald power allows me to feel.
I can't see a thing, but it's around somewhere.
I gotta hold my head.
I have no fear.
It probably seems crazy, crazy, graveyard theory.
A ghost tried to approach me.
He got leery.
Spooky up in here.
It's crazy in here.
We still gotta keep it going.
I'm Knuckles.
Nobody scares me.
Oh.
Who dares me?
Whoever wants it?
Bring it.
I don't care.
We can do this.
They come step up to the plate.
Mr. Match.
It ain't no thing.
I went in deeper.
I didn't listen to the lyrics before that.
genuine reaction first time wow thank you pumpkin hill pumpkin hill a ghost pumpkin soup
i'm glad i didn't practice that one mean to the enchilada no
yeah oh i said i was gonna to eat some a thingy Hold on, let me put on some Halloween music.
Hold on, let me have a mint.
And then we can chat, and then I'll do some more song.
Last song will, ironically, be from Ghostbusters.
Why are you trying to call my set list, huh?
You don't know anything.
It's not what I had planned, actually.
Minto eating a mint?
Cannibalism!
Actually, I have to find something.
I have to find a certain karaoke of something, actually.
Are you guys feeling Halloween mood?
Do you guys do trick-or-treaters?
More cannibalism.
Do you guys do... do you die?
I almost said, do you guys do cannibalism?
Do you guys do trick-or-treaters?
Yeah, I know, I used to.
I don't get any at my maid cafe.
I think they're too scared.
I think they maybe think it's, uh, maybe they think it's abandoned.
I mean, it kind of is, but, you know, I would still leave, like, a bowl out or something if anybody came by, nobody shows up.
Sad.
I turned the lights down and pretend I'm not home.
You're the house nobody likes.
I don't know where my Bustin...
I don't know where my Bustin instrumental is.
Wait, it might be.
Oh wait, hold on.
Under here maybe?
No?
I have no idea.
Let me search.
Bustin.
Oh, Bustin!
I found it.
I'm not going to do it just yet, though.
Are you guys having fun?
Are you guys enjoying the karaoke?
Bustin.
half my neighborhood band's Halloween oh safety oh yeah I guess people do get rowdy huh while working are you working hard or hardly working are you guys feeling the Halloween are you guys feeling the Halloween spirit of my Possessing you enough?
Well, enough?
Also working.
Don't work too hard.
Make sure you guys get some rest too.
Oima!
The greatest karaoke stream of all time.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah!
This is so good.
Did you guys see the Oimo art for the main cafe club with Asayoru?
I wish I could show you my thighs.
Oimo was just like, You will have booty.
I got here late.
Well, thanks for dropping by.
Thank you.
Have you ever played Corpse Party?
Yeah, I love Corpse Party.
Shangri-La from that game.
But I don't remember it.
I wish I could show it.
But let me look it up.
It got sent...
It got sent to me, but now I can't find it.
I almost played a corpse party for October.
But it's not that it's a lot of voice acting because it's voiced in Japanese, but...
I don't know.
I don't know why I didn't.
Would you try out FNAF one day?
Like the game?
Play it!
I played the ball pit.
I played the ball pit game.
I'll be giving out candy this year.
Yippee!
My neighborhood gets a lot of trick-or-treaters.
It has since I was a kid.
Wait, that's so fun!
It's a lot of reading.
I love Corpse Party though.
It's so good.
You
can't mention thighs without follow-up.
I can't show you the pictures.
You'll have to wait until Aseyoru shows the full image.
So, sorry, sorry.
Okay.
I finished my cough drop.
Let's do...
Another song!
Update your March link.
It still goes to...
That's still the main link at the moment.
The other one expires at the end of the month, so...
I know what I'm doing.
Stop policing me!
My goodness!
Take a page out of your book and play RE6 of the Buddy.
Oh, nice!
Have fun!
Kupokan.
is coming to Montreal this weekend.
I'll be cosplaying rude from FF7 Rebirth.
Can I get a make new friends?
BEEP!
Good luck, customer.
You'll be rude.
Well, don't be rude, but you know.
Don't be rude, but like, but you know.
But be rude.
And people will be like, wow, that's rude.
That's rude.
Don't have people be like, that's rude.
And not be like, that's rude.
I also learned this, well, okay, I knew this song.
But I also didn't know this song.
You know when you, like, hear a song all the time and then you don't learn it, like, properly?
So I'm going to try with this one.
Who's watching me?
I'm just an average man with an average life.
Why are you speaking?
I work from nine to five.
Hell, I pay the price.
All I want is to be left alone.
in my average home.
But why do I always feel like I'm in the twilight zone?
And I always feel like somebody's watching me.
And I have no privacy.
Oh, I always feel like somebody's watching me.
Tell me.
Is there
a way I broke the door real tight?
People call me on the phone.
I'm trying to avoid.
Can people see TV, TV, or am I just paranoid?
When I'm in the shower, I'm afraid to wash my hair Because I might open my eyes and find someone standing there People say I'm crazy I'm just a little touched But maybe showers remind me of psycho Too much, that's why I always feel like somebody's watching me And I have no privacy Oh,
I always feel like somebody's watching
me I don't know anymore Are the neighbors watching me?
Well, is the mailman watching me?
Watch it.
And I don't feel safe anymore.
Oh, what a mess.
I wonder who's watching me now.
The IRS!
I always feel like somebody's watching me.
And I have no privacy.
Oh, I always feel like somebody's watching me.
Tell me, is it just a dream?
I always feel like somebody's watching me And I have no privacy I always feel like somebody
I always feel like somebody's watching me
I always feel like somebody's watching
Surely it couldn't be the people that are watching the stream, right?
Right?
No, no!
Surely is surely.
That's not my name.
Gosh, I always get it wrong.
That was somebody's watching me.
Spooky's always.
Well, thank you so much, Redox.
Thank you.
Okay, this one.
Sorry, Minto.
I'll stop watching.
No!
Come back.
This next one, hold on.
Let me get it.
I have to do something special with it.
So give me a second.
Don't listen.
Okay, there we go.
All right.
Hold on.
Hello.
give me one second sorry if you heard it for a second if it was loud i hope it wasn't loud i can't hear it oh there it is uh there and
there okay and okay i fix it you guys know what time it is You guys know what time it is?
I can't do regular Ghostbusters, you guys, because I don't know it.
So we have our special version.
I actually, back before I went to heaven, I would end my stream.
Almost every time with this song.
I would end it with this song almost every single time.
Such nostalgia.
Every time I hear this song, it's such nostalgia for me.
So please listen...
Bustin!
Wait, did I?
Hold on.
There we go.
There's something strange sleeping in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
That there's something weird sleeping in your bed.
Bustin makes me feel good.
Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin
Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin
Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting.
Makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good.
Geek Ghost Man.
Freaking Man, baby!
Let me sleep in your bed.
I
am afraid of no sleep.
I am afraid of no bed.
Busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting.
Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin
Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin
Bustin I remember Ghostbusters being this freaky I definitely remember it being that freaky I definitely remember Ghostbusters being very freaky.
Guys, it's a little bit of a shorter stream.
I think I kind of like flew through these songs, but that's okay.
I had 20 songs and one encore song.
But I have just a couple songs left.
Just a couple songs.
20 songs in two hours.
It's kind of crazy though, no?
This one is one that you all have been waiting for.
I was working in the lab late one night when my eyes beheld an eerie sight for my monster from his slab began to rise and suddenly to my surprise He did the monster mash The monster mash It was a graveyard smash He did the mash It cut on in a flash He did the mash He did the monster mash From my laboratory in the castle east To the master bedroom where the vampires feast The ghouls all came from their humble abodes To get a jolt from my electrodes They did the mash Monster Mash It was a graveyard smash They did the mash It caught on in a flash They did the mash They did the monster mash The zombies were having fun The party had just begun The guests included Wolfman Dracula and his son The scene was rocking And all great,
well wait, oh, is it?
Igor on chains backed in his bang house.
The coffin bangers were about to arrive with their vocal group, the Crypt Kikrfan.
They played the MASH.
They played the Monster MASH.
The Monster MASH.
And it was a graveyard smash.
They played the MASH.
It caught on in a flash.
They played the Monster MASH.
Out from his coffin, Drax hoisted ring, Seems he was troubled by just one thing.
He opened the lid and shook his fist and said, Whatever happened to my Transylvania twins?
It's now the MASH!
It's now the Monster Mash!
The Monster Mash!
Now it's a graveyard smash!
It's now the MASH!
It caught on in a flash!
It's now the Monster Mash!
Now everything's cool, Jack's part of the band, And my Monster Mash!
It's the hit of the land.
For you the living, this mash was meant to.
When you get to my door, tell them Boris sent you.
Then you can mash.
Then you can monster mash.
Monster mash.
And do my graveyard smash.
Then you can mash.
You'll catch on in a flash.
Then you can monster mash.
Oh, mash good.
Easy, Igor, you impetuous young boy.
Oh, Mashgood.
I don't want to do this anymore.
I don't want to do this again.
Monster Magic Power.
Did I surprise you guys?
Did you think it was going to be the Braindraw version?
I got you.
I spared you.
I'm down the two songs left
But thank you guys I feel very in the Halloween spirit After this I'm gonna drink some tea That is like Apple flavored So good It puts me so much into the spirit of Halloween Can you sing Monster Mash today?
Wait that was so long ago now Look
what I missed in!
Hello, Beehive.
Hello, everybody.
Hi, hi.
I saw you were playing Blitz vs.
Harpers.
Yeah.
Also, thank you so much for the pink.
Thank you so much.
And all the gifted.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Really, really appreciate it.
Yeah.
I have one song left and then an encore.
okay which one is it i think it's this one let me double check
yeah yeah yeah
it's kind of a it's kind of a tonal whiplash but i wanted to sing this one last because i think it's a really nice song it's not like super spooky but it does it does also help welcome fall so yeah
Why are you speaking?
Sorry.
One more time.
Then through the mist, by the milk light of moon, all that was lost is revealed.
Our long bygone burdens, mere echoes of the spring.
But where have we come?
And where shall we end?
If dreams can't come true, then why not pretend?
How the gentle wind beckons through the leaves as autumn colors fall.
in a swirl of golden memories the loveliest lies of all
a little short one thank you guys for um again for today it was a lot of fun i'm singing all these halloween spooky songs and yeah you guys get some good i hope you guys get more treats than tricks unless the tricks are coming from me like this next thing yeah one last song yeah i was edging oh so i did it earlier
beheld a skippity sighed, for the true Sigma Rizzler began to rise and violently mugged the Costco guys.
He did the mash.
He rist up all the guys.
The monster mash.
Gave them a smash or a bash.
He did the mash.
He put the fries in the bag.
He rist up all the guys.
From the back rooms in the Ohio streets, where the wolf The gooners all joked to grow their chodes To get tips from me cause I'm a looks max pro They did the mash He rizzed up all the gats The monster mash Gave them a smash or a pass They did the mash They put the fries in the bag They did the mash He rizzed up all the gats The streamers were all doing the gritty Baby Gronk just rizzed up Livy The Rizzler brought Big Justice!
Aiden Ross and Kai Senat!
There were no bobs in sight, everyone began to mew!
Patrick Bateman on Ox...
What?
Buckle my shoe!
Blue Tie Kid on his Sigma Grind, Turkish Cundale Dingle Dance, Dregsa Prime!
These are not words, he rizzed up all the cats!
Monster Mash!
They've never smashed or passed!
They've made the mash!
They play the mesh He rizzed up all the gas Pausing his stream Mint phantom did yapp Seems like Donkey Bird was About to cap Looked around to see if there was enough movement And said Did you guys know the low taper meme is still massive?
He's now the mesh He rizzed up all the gas The monster mesh Gave them a smash or a pass They put the fry to the bag He's now the mesh Here is to Paul the Gats!
Everybody loves Skibbidee's Ultimate Giga Chat, and my brainwroth bash is the hits of the land!
For you, the beta, this bash was meant to...
The funniest meme ever is Hawk Tua!
Then you can mash!
Here is to Paul the Gats!
A monster mash!
Gave them a smash or a pass!
Then you can mash!
Here is to... I'll put the prize in the bag!
Here is to Paul the Gats!
Yes!
Ooh, get good.
Oh, easy Matara, you sussy Ohio.
Mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm.
Oh, oh, get good.
Oh, easy Matara, easy Matara.
Ooh, get good.
Oh!